alright hello everybody okay so this is
a pretty exciting lecture because now
we're able to start actually computing
solutions of partial differential
equations in MATLAB which is awesome so
just a show of hands how many of you
have solved a PDE before in on a
computer see - any more than two okay so
this is going to hopefully be pretty
interesting let's see a couple of
logistical things so I just posted
solutions to homework 1 and homework 2
then I realized homework twos not due
until this afternoon so I took homework
two down but it'll be due I'll post the
solutions like sometime this weekend so
if you absolutely need an extension on
this homework you have to tell me now
like immediately or else I'm not going
to take any late homeworks because I'm
going to post the solutions today so you
can like see them I was going to post a
homework three but I think I'm going to
do it after some day because I don't
want anyone to do anything except focus
their energy for the Seahawks winning
all right
and I've also posted all of the lecture
notes up to date and everything through
today's lecture is fair game for the
midterm okay and the midterm will be
handed out on Wednesday by handed out I
mean it'll be posted here on this
website on Wednesday after class okay
let's take home exam same rules as last
time any questions at all
no okay all right so this is pretty
exciting because I'm going to start to
get into a few really important concepts
today that I hope are things that you
take with you for a long time so in the
last two lectures we solved we solve
Laplace's equation analytically by hand
right and it was kind of messy alright
we got a bunch of signs and cinches and
an infinite series which seems pretty
nasty and so what we're going to do
today is we're going to show that the
expression we derived is actually pretty
simple to implement in MATLAB so we'll
be able to the cool thing is we'll be
able to solve this heat equation on a
rectangular domain with arbitrary
arbitrary boundary conditions so these
could be any nasty function that you
like of temperature on the boundaries
I'm also going to show you how to solve
this Laplace's equation without any
analytic formulas like without any
cinches or sines we're just going to do
it purely numerically just like we solve
numerically ODS using OD 45 we're going
to cook up schemes to solve these PDE s
numerically okay what else am I going to
do yeah and this is really important
we're going to start introducing the
concept of Fourier transforms today and
this is all that I'm going to talk about
next week our Fourier transforms and how
they are useful in PD ES and how they're
useful for representing functions like
our boundary conditions in a nice way in
terms of sine waves okay
all right so we're going to solve
Laplace's equation numerically on the
computer and there's a couple things we
can do so I'm going to give you like
five or six different
patience for solving this we're going to
try them all out in MATLAB and we're
going to see which one's work best
okay so numeric solution until applause
equation okay so just for my review one
is Laplace's equation del squared u
equals zero okay so this is a function
of two variables this would be partial
squared partial X plus partial squared
partial Y of U equals zero okay and this
is a linear operator alright this is a
linear operator in U so if I have two
solutions u 1 and u 2 and their sum is
also a solution okay so the first
technique is actually kind of
interesting so what we're going to do is
we're going to use the heat equation UT
equals some constant del squared U and
we're going to try to solve this
iteratively we're going to start with
some initial condition some initial
guess and we're going to iterate it
forward in time and we're actually going
to let the heat equilibrate using the
heat equation write the Laplace's
equation is the solution as time goes to
infinity of this equation with alpha
positive constants okay so how can we
solve this kind of a this kind of a PDE
on a computer what are what are what
general approach should we take to
solving these things on a computer
something like a Newton Rapson
for which part
for this part or for this part the UFT
part okay okay so we have this U of T
part and this del square du part we're
going to need some way of representing
both of these maybe I should ask a more
basic question how are we even going to
represent the solution in a computer
sorry
but what do I want out at the end I want
a movie I want to see my heat
distribution evolving in time to send
equilibrium and what is that movie going
to have its going to have frames in the
movie and each frame is going to be a
rectangle right with colors so what I
want is you to be a matrix okay you is
going to be a two dimensional array in
MATLAB it's going to be a big array of
numbers okay and I'm going to try to
update that array of numbers using this
essentially differential equation this
is like an OD e for every single little
grid cell in this array of numbers okay
so I'm going to have this
two-dimensional array of temperatures at
every point in X and Y and I'm going to
figure out how at each point x and y how
does that little grid cells temperature
change as a function of its neighboring
grid cells okay so the first crudest
thing we can do so this U is like this
big kind of array looking thing right
like it's a big matrix or you know super
tall vector if you want to think about
it like that
so the crudest approximation to this
time derivative what do we learn from
564 what's the what's the simplest first
derivative we can take
sorry I heard boiler what else like a
forward difference so we're going to say
that this is U at time t plus delta t
minus U at time T divided by delta T
equals alpha laplacian of u and i'm
basically going to take an initial
condition U at time this is U at time T
I'm going to take some initial condition
at time 0 and I want to step it to time
one time two times three and so on so
what I want is U at time T plus delta T
as a function of the previous time step
so that's equal to u plus Alpha Delta T
laplacian of U at time T so this defines
an iteration if I have some initial
guess u naught u know u at x 0 then I
apply this formula and I get U at time 1
then I apply it again I get U at time to
U at time 3 dot dot dot dot and
eventually I get u equilibrium which is
the solution of Laplace's equation so
this is this isn't anything you know
super fancy we're just doing what we've
done before and 564 to solve this Oh de
ok I'm thinking of this equation as a
really big Oh de with you know M by n
ordinary differential equations so let's
say that there are maybe L by H so I'm
going to have L by H ordinary
differential equations and this is the
formula to iterate all of those ordinary
differential equations forward using
forward Euler so forward Euler is the
crudest thing we can try
but it's going to work which is kind of
cool okay does this make sense okay so
what's the next thing we have to do in
this equation so we've figured out this
term what's the next hard part yeah how
do we figure out what this laplacian of
u is so what is the laplacian of u okay
partial squared u with respect to x
squared plus partial squared with
respect to y squared
okay so at every single grid point you
know at every IJ grid point here I and J
are indices for my grid points they go
from index you know 1 to L 1 to M do we
know how to compute these partial
derivatives yes okay how do we compute
these partial derivatives so first of
all there's a really easy command in
MATLAB called del 2 so del 2 will
compute the laplacian of my matrix okay
so this is the easiest and most accurate
but I don't really know what del 2 is
doing under the hood so I'm going to
tell you how we would do this by hand if
you had to so how would you compute this
derivative by hand if you needed to
right you take finite differences in the
x-direction to get the second derivative
and X and finite differences in the
y-direction to get your partial
derivatives in Y and this is essentially
this method is called a stencil that's
kind of a cool idea so let's say that I
have my domain with all of my data
points right this is a big array you
just write all these down let's say that
this is my large rectangle rectangular
domain and so the idea is if I want to
compute the partial derivative the
laplacian at this point I can
essentially do that by considering
finite differences with its neighbors ok
so this is what we're going to do we
have so let's call this the I J point
and if we want to compute the laplacian
of u at the IJ point we're going to use
this five-point stencil meaning we're
going to use the data from the five
points around it from it and the four
points surrounding it its nearest
neighbors okay this is called a five
point stencil okay and it's actually
super duper easy to figure out what this
derivative should be you can also figure
out how accurate the derivative is you
can cook up higher order accurate
schemes using nine point stencils and
eighteen point stencils or there's all
kinds of fancier ways of doing this if
you take a larger and larger window to
compute these derivatives just like we
did in in 1d functions okay and though
the func the formula is pretty simple so
this is I J this is I plus 1 J I minus 1
J I J plus 1 and I J minus 1
okay so what is my partial derivative
what's my first derivative okay I'm just
going to write it down so first I'm
going to do my partial derivative and X
okay so partial u partial X is U I plus
1 J minus u I J divided by Delta X
that's this partial u partial X here I'm
using I'm finding the first derivative
using forward difference and then I'm
going to subtract the first derivative
using backwards difference and divide by
Delta X minus UI J minus UI minus 1 J
divided by Delta X divided by Delta X
and this is the second partial
derivative I'm basically just computing
two first derivatives here and then I'm
using I'm taking the first derivative of
those first derivatives that's what this
is and you can work it out that this is
really I mean this is we've done this
before this is just the the second order
central difference that we derived in
the last quarter ok you can do a similar
thing for partial squared u partial Y
squared that's basically the same stuff
except instead of varying the I index
the X direction we're going to be taking
this along the Y slice by varying the J
index so pretty straightforward
we have U of I J plus 1 minus u I J
divided by Delta Y minus u I J minus u I
J minus 1 divided by Delta Y divided by
Delta Y
and so let's just get rid of this and
write out what the solution is so I'm
going to assume that Delta X equals
Delta Y and I'm going to add these two
things up to get the laplacian so my
laplacian equals 1 over Delta x squared
I'm assuming Delta Y is equal to Delta
x1 over Delta x squared times okay what
do I have I have a positive I have a
positive value of this point that's here
I have a positive value of this point a
positive value of this point and a
positive value of this point so these
four points I have a positive value of U
I plus 1 J plus u I minus 1 J plus UI J
plus 1 plus U at I J minus 1 and then I
have four negative copies of you in the
middle I have four negative copies of my
central points and index I J so minus
for you at I J ok so this is a really
simple formula if I had a function
defined on this array if I had my
temperature distribution u naught or u1
or u2 or whatever then I could compute
its laplacian using this formula and I
would just write a huge for loop through
I all the eyes and all the J's and I
would have the laplacian at every point
this only works for interior points
right this function has I plus ones and
J plus one so it only works for the
middle the middle points
okay should we code this up and try it I
think we have all the ingredients we
need we know how to compute this
iteration in time this is time and we
know how to compute this laplacian of u
if we have an array a rectangular grid
of points okay so we're ready to code
this up let's try it again
this seems like I should go farther down
let's try that for now okay
okay that works for me okay so what
we're going to do we're going to solve
the same basic setup that we had derived
an analytic solution for in last class
we're going to have a rectangle and this
rectangle does not have to be square but
I'm just going to make it square because
why not so it goes from 0 to L 0 to H
and it's going to have 0 temperatures on
the top and bottom it's going to have we
could do anything this is completely
general but I'm going to have it have a
temperature fixed at 1 on the left and
the right okay we could do something
else if we wanted okay so I made a color
map for the Seahawks just this morning
on my bus ride over people thought I was
crazy and this is what the iteration
looks like in time so I'll just show you
what the solution is and I will walk
through what all the math does and what
all of this means but what we have is an
imposed temperature on the left and the
right wall is equal to 1 okay and we see
that for long times our temperature is 1
we have an imposed temperature of 0 on
the top and the bottom which is also
satisfied and as time is evolving we
have our temperature kind of diffusing
into the middle where they're meeting
okay which is kind of what we expect to
happen it looks so much better on my
computer screen that it's kind of
irritating let me see if I can make this
larger okay I can I can make a figure
and I can set my position 100 600 by 600
see if this works
ah but I lost my Seahawks color let's
try again
okay and I bet I can make it 800 by 800
maybe seven by seven
I'm killing all the lights to help it
all okay so you can see these kind of
ISO contours that are in the middle and
if you could see a little bit better you
would see that there are these kind of
hyperbolic looking level sets of this
function which makes sense because our
solution has hyperbolic sines and
cosines that doesn't help okay all right
so that's what the solution looks like
now let's go through and figure out how
we actually coded this up so I told you
there were a bunch of options right the
first one was to use okay let's let's
just start from scratch so the first
thing I do is I create a 100 by 100
square and I say that my temperature
distribution starts out being 0 okay and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
iterate my heat equation two thousand
times for two thousand DTS I'm going to
iterate my heat equation so this should
come into equilibrium and every single
one of these iterations the first thing
I'm going to do is enforce my boundary
conditions
whatever happened to mess up my boundary
conditions I'm going to rewrite over
that I'm going to say no the temperature
is fixed at zero on the top and the
bottom and it's fixed to be 1 on the
left and the right okay so I'm manually
fixing my boundary conditions by just
overriding those numbers in the array
with the zeros and ones now technically
I don't think I have to do this I think
I could bring this whole thing out and
it would work ok good so I wrote this
code correctly okay so I'm not ever
changing those boundary conditions
okay so inside my iteration I do the
following thing the first thing I do is
you know every ten iterations I just
plot the thing so we're seeing this it's
doing ten to ten DTS and then it plots
ten more DTS and then it plots it gets
really slow if you do it otherwise so
this is just plotting and option one I'm
using the del to command to compute my
laplacian okay I told you that there's
this function del - and it computes
remember we had you K plus 1 equals UK
plus Delta t alpha times the laplacian
of U at time K so there's a function in
MATLAB called del 2 and it computes the
laplacian of u now I call this L of U
because this is a linear operator in u L
of U is usually what I use for linear
operator so this is L of U okay that's
this line here 34 so I compute my
laplacian using the slick MATLAB command
and now what I do is I take all of my
interior points here in the middle I get
a little marker so I take all of my
interior points and I inert them forward
using this this formula okay so I evolve
I know that my boundary conditions
aren't changing so I don't need to
change them in time
I'm fixing them and so all of the
interior points once I've computed this
laplacian I update them with this
formula that makes sense I take my old
solution plus some constant times the
laplacian of u so I say all of the
interior points from 2 to L minus 1 & 2
to H minus 1 all the interior points are
going to equal their old solution plus
some number times my laplacian
so this makes sense yeah does this not
make sense to anyone I can go through it
more carefully right this is a big array
and this is a big array and those
correspond to you at my last time step
and my laplacian of you okay now what if
I made this constant delta T times alpha
larger right maybe I want this to
converge more quickly I want my heat
equation to be more aggressive so I'm
either going to have more thermal
diffusion or I'm going to have a larger
time constant those are the two ways I
could do it so let's say I make this 2
times the laplacian of u what do we
expect might happen to this equation if
I make DT or alpha too large
say again well I could converge faster
or it could go unstable those are the
two options it's either going to
converge faster until it doesn't and
then it will diverge to infinity so
let's see what happens when I make this
larger ok so notice now that this is
essentially this is 10 to the 300 right
that was a huge number going to infinity
it's still diverging let me make this a
little smaller
okay so what we notice is that very
quickly the numbers get extremely large
and we have this weird instability
growing okay and so this iteration
becomes completely unstable I have this
weird checker pattern anyone know why
this is a checkered pattern starting
from the corners any guesses at all
so the corner is the most tricky point
that's true these corners are where you
have almost an infinite you know kind of
derivative what else could possibly be
causing this
so this checker pattern corresponds to
the highest frequency sine wave that you
could possibly have on this discrete
grid okay if the highest frequency sine
wave in both x and y and it turns out
that that wave number that frequency if
I took this partial differential
equation and Fourier transform it formed
it I would still have a differential
equation and the differential equation
for the highest frequency wave number is
the most unstable so it's growing the
fastest and when I plot it all I see is
that one ripple a super high frequency
pattern so we're going to understand
this a lot better next week when we look
at Fourier analysis but we're starting
to see sine waves here this checker
pattern to me says really really high
frequency sine wave is unstable okay so
we're just going to tone this back down
to a reasonable constant of one that's
as good as we can do okay well you can
do a little better but that's basically
as good as we can do okay so that was
one option is just to use the del to
command to compute this laplacian but I
spent all the time explaining this
five-point stencil so I want to
implement this five-point stencil so
instead of just computing the laplacian
using del two I'm going to compute the
laplacian for every point I and J using
the stencil we talked about okay so for
all of the interior points in both x and
y for i to 2l minus 1 J 2 to H minus 1
this laplacian at point I J is going to
equal this formula that I derived and
I'm just going to assume that Delta X
equals 1 because I don't want to think
about it I don't want to normalize
anything or divided by Delta X's so I
just have minus 4 of you in the middle
plus a positive U at each of its
neighbors and the plus sign that's it
and then I do the exact same numerical
iteration scheme right I do the same
forward euler time step to iterate my u
solution forward in time now notice that
I need a smaller
smaller integration factor here because
this is actually less numerically stable
than this del 2 del 2 is more accurate
than this crappy five-point stencil and
so this I have to take really small time
steps or else my error blows up we'll
look at that in a minute okay so now
we're doing this option 1b we're using a
five-point stencil basically we get the
thing we want doesn't look like it's
changing much on the screen but a lot of
interesting stuff is happening so I
encourage you to actually run this code
on a computer screen ok does that make
sense how we're essentially now all
we're doing is computing this laplacian
ourselves and we're doing kind of
something silly that's not as good as
what MATLAB is doing MATLAB is actually
probably taking the Fourier transform
and it's laplacian is much much much
much more accurate than ours
which is why it's so much more
numerically stable another option is to
do something called an 8-point stencil
which instead of looking at just the
four nearest neighbors I look at my
eight nearest neighbors and basically I
say that my middle point you know minus
eight of my middle point plus one
positive value at each of these eight
neighboring points so this is an eight
point stencil there's all kinds of
stencils there's a whole pretty
interesting theory about these stencils
there's books written Wikipedia pages
but for our purposes we get the same
solution every time and I like Dell too
because I don't have to type any for
loops for loops are terrible in that lab
so Dell is way way way way way way
better okay please interrupt if there's
any questions at this point this
basically makes sense
okay there's another thing we can do so
I told you that option one was to start
with the heat equation and iterate it
forward alright another thing we can do
that's actually pretty it makes a lot of
sense is I can take my stencil formula
and I can just try to make Laplace's
equation true at every time step so
option two is try to manually enforce
del squared u equals zero at each
iteration so for example in my
five-point stencil we know that our
laplacian looks like the follow
we have laplacian of u you know at the
IJ grade point equals well it equals
something like 1 over delta x squared
times minus 4 u at IJ plus u at all of
its neighbors right these are my
neighbors so I could make this manually
equal zero in a pretty simple way I
could just set this thing equal to zero
and solve for my function at I J I could
say u I J and I'm going to get rid of
Delta x squared in my simulation all
these Delta X's are 1 so this is just
equal to 1/4 times the sum of all of my
neighbors now what is that this formula
look like what is 1/4 of the sum of the
values of all of my neighbors
the average I'm literally taking my
neighbors and I'm figuring out what
their values are and I'm averaging them
and overriding you I give you the same
thing with my eight point stencil I
could have one over eight times the sum
of my eight nearest neighbors okay this
is a perfectly valid way to solve
Laplace's equation and we could iterate
this forward and this will converge
towards the true solution okay so that's
option two I'm going to code this one up
now really glad I pre coded all of this
okay so option two is we're going to
forget the heat equation we're going to
iteratively try to make Laplace's
equation equal zero with our five-point
stencil so what I'm doing here now is
I'm this is a I shouldn't have called
this L of U but now I have my average
function of U this is the average of all
of my neighbors it's just one quarter of
the sum of all of my neighbors and now
all of my interior points at every
iteration I just set them equal to the
average of their neighbors this seems
like incredibly simple but it works okay
totally works
okay so we are solving PDEs numerically
in MATLAB right now okay we have the
tools to solve laplacian x' and DDT's if
I put in some nonlinear stuff you could
solve those two this is not the best way
to solve PDS numerically but this
definitely works okay this is a starting
place we can actually do something now
okay and we can start to we can start to
have more interesting boundary
conditions too so for example I'm going
to have this new boundary condition
where on my right-hand portion of my
square I'm going to impose a sinusoidal
temperature distribution okay just a
sine 2pi 1 to L over L that doesn't work
let's see I have to do something I I
commented out all of my options so I'm
actually not solving anything I did this
a lot of times in my office so okay so
this is what the heat distribution looks
like as it evolves for a sine wave
distribution so you have plus on the top
- on the bottom and you can see that
these are just getting kind of wider and
wider and wider as they encroach on the
domain but the zero temperature boundary
conditions out here are essentially
bleeding away a lot of that energy okay
kind of cool you can do any temperature
distribution you like no problem okay
okay that's what I want to show you for
now in MATLAB there's more I want to
show you if there's time so that's how
to code this up using finite differences
this is the crudest thing we could do we
did forward Euler and central difference
for the laplacian very very crude but it
does work we're going to figure out much
better ways to solve this use
Fourier transforms so even even in
computers we would like to solve this in
the Fourier frequency-domain it's much
easier
but first what I want to do is I want to
show you in our example from last class
we actually derived an analytic solution
to the temperature distribution for an
arbitrary function of Y on the right
hand side right we had this huge nasty
expression we spent two lectures finding
it and so what I want to do is show you
that you can also code this up in MATLAB
and it's actually a useful quantity okay
so I believe what we had was U of x and
y equals the sum from N equals 1 to
infinity of a n sine n PI / hy cinch n
PI / H X and this a n was pretty nasty
we had a n equals the sum horrible
expression like 2 over H cinch blah blah
blah and PI L over this is terrible
integral 0 to H F of Y times a sine wave
in Y dy ok
now this looks terrible but it's
actually not terrible these are all
numbers H is a number L is a number and
and PI are numbers 2 is a number of
these are all numbers okay in MATLAB we
can solve this super easy now let's try
that example that we just did where we
have this sine wave so f of y equals and
it's not just a sine wave its sine of 2
pi Y over H it has exactly one period
from zero to H so it's 2 pi Y over H
that's my function of Y let's try to
plug this into here and see if we got
something that's simple
okay so what's the first thing I need to
do sorry I need to find these eggs these
eggs are like basically if I have AIDS
then I can plot this you I have this you
so I need to find all these aids now
what do we know about if I plug in a
sine wave in here what do I know about
how it integrates with other sine waves
so this was a homework this is why I
gave you that weird homework about
integrating sine waves this will
integrate to zero for all frequencies
and except and equals to so a n not
equal to R all zero a of n is equal to
zero for all N that's not equal to 2 and
a 2 is actually kind of simple so it's
equal to 2 over H cinch shove 2 pi L
over H this is just a number
integral 0 to H of sine 2 pi over H
squared dy I can integrate this in
MATLAB and I'll get a number out and
then that number I can multiply it by
this single frequency in space X&Y and I
get my function you kind of cool so
let's do that
yes all right okay so I have this l11
lecture 11 analytic laplacian same deal
I have a grid from 0 to 100 0 to 100 or
maybe 1 to 100 1 to 100 l was 100 H is
100 I create a big mesh grid for X&Y I
start out with zero temperature
distribution and what I'm going to do
here is I'm analytically solving for the
temperature distribution this is no
iteration
there's no heat equation no look
discrete laplacian I have my boundary
condition function this is my F of Y
just 2 pi Y over H is my variable Y it's
a vector of Y variables I have my
constant a to which I can solve exactly
how I wrote it here and then my u
function is just a 2 times sine of that
frequency and Y times Cinch of that
frequency in X and I'm going to apply it
super simple and I get my temperature
distribution like that no iteration this
is the infinite time Laplace temperature
distribution it's also there's no
numerical error here this is completely
mean except for the Machine precision of
cinches and sines this is exactly the
right answer and it was really simple to
solve in MATLAB all of these nasty
integrals and functions are easy they're
just you know sums and signs and cinches
does this make sense how we did this ok
I want you to look at this code if it
doesn't this is important stuff what if
I had a nastier boundary condition what
if I had a nastier boundary condition
that wasn't just a nice sign then what
would we do
what if F of Y was not a nice single
sine wave then I would have to just
integrate over at a bunch of times I
would have to I would have to compute
this a n a bunch of times I'd have a
computer for N equals one two three four
five up to maybe 100 and I'd have a
hundred of these signs and cinches that
I'm adding up but I know what the
coefficients are and I know what the
frequencies are so I can do that so the
last example I'm going to do and by the
way this is exactly like a numerically
taking the Fourier transform so the last
thing I'm going to do this is my hard
analytic laplacian is now I'm going to
solve this for the boundary condition we
did earlier which is zero zero zero one
this is a hard boundary condition for
first sines and cosines so this is my
function of Y it's just one at all of
these hundred points my boundary
condition is just a big vector of one
hundred ones and now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take my temperature
distribution set it initially equal to 0
's and I'm going to add up a 1 times
sine of the first frequency since of the
first frequency plus a 2 sine of the
second frequency since of the second
frequency and so on for K equals 1/2
some number let's try ok I'll show you
the final answer I'm going to add all
hundred of these Fourier modes and I get
exactly the right temperature
distribution that I would expect we
could verify this using our other code
fact why don't we just do that take our
other code and
so our other code iterates eventually to
the same solution except this has a much
a numerical error and it's kind of
crappy but basically this is what it's
supposed to look like is some kind of
weird shape that's bleeding towards the
left but we can get it almost
instantaneously here by adding up these
hundred sine waves and this is the
infinite time distribution this is
actually much more accurate so let's see
what happens if I just have the first
mode not terrible what about the first
five minutes interesting I wish you
could see this a little clearer it gets
bright then dim then bright then dim
then bright it's beating weird let's try
the first ten modes that's interesting
it gets bright Jen right dim bright dim
bright dim bright dim looks like ten
switches I'm having 10 modes if I did 20
it would be a little bit better until
eventually I have enough modes that that
alternating pattern is smaller than my
dy okay so the basic idea here this is
this example is completely designed to
motivate Fourier transforms the idea is
that I can have an arbitrary function
completely nasty function and what I
want to do is I want to find these a of
N equal you know all of this stuff I
want to find the coefficients of that
function in a sine wave basis
I want to decompose my function I want
to rewrite my function as a sum of sine
waves of low frequencies to high
frequencies of various frequencies so
this is essentially where the Fourier
transform comes from is writing my
function Y my function of Y as a sum of
sine waves it's now a function of
frequencies okay these AAS and if we can
do that
we can solve all of these pcs
numerically very quickly very accurately
and we can solve them for nasty
geometries and much harder equations
than just Laplace's equations okay so
this basic idea is what we're going to
use to introduce Fourier transforms on
Monday that's everything I have have a
great weekend and I'll see you on Monday